Washington DC's new streetcar line was
ill-planned ill-thought-out ill
engineer's ill everything recently
deceased former mayor Marion Barry said
in 2014 there have been minor accidents
constant engineering problems and the
system is missed its targeted opening
date by more than three years perhaps DC
planners never would have embarked on
this folly if only they'd studied the
long and turbulent history of streetcars
in the city for about a hundred years
these surface-level rail cars crisscross
the Capitol although they were an
important technology in their time
streetcars involved major engineering
headaches and they required an enormous
amount of capital investment in
maintenance contrary to the myth peddled
by transit nostalgics when streetcars
finally disappeared from the district in
1962 the public collectively breathes a
sigh of relief now that the new DC
streetcar is finally allegedly set to
open in a few weeks there's a new book
out called Capitol streetcar it
meticulously recounts the story of the
old system the book which is straight
objective history and doesn't take a
position on whether building new
streetcars is good policy or not was
written by John de Ferrari a local
historian who writes regularly at the
streets of Washington blog his book
begins by describing what it was like
getting around Washington DC before
streetcars first appeared in the 1860s
it was very tough to travel long
distances beginning in the 1830s or so
there were so-called omnibus alike you
see in movies or the Old West I ran over
DC's dirty muddy streets and they were
generally loathed by everyone as being
very slow mile per hour roughly a a
couple miles per hour at best so why not
just walk
well that would that's a great question
most people did just walk okay so
streetcars come along and they're a
really big deal so what's the technology
what's different cars are running on
Rails a horse pulling in a streetcar can
pull ten times the weight a carriage it
was leveraging the power of the horses
and it did that very well electricity
fully replaces horses in the streetcar
era really takes off
there's this gold rush of private
companies trying to get in what happens
so d/c beyond the central core is very
hilly area you could never have
horse-drawn streetcars go out to the
what were then the suburbs the outer
part of DC and so this was a huge thing
you could build the suburbs and make
money selling the houses and people
could get down to their work easily but
it was not as big a money-making
opportunities people thought that was
the catch with it they were very
expensive to build and if you had a new
suburb just getting started you would
have very few people there to begin with
taking the cars and and the streetcar
line would would tend to not make money
talk about some of the engineering
problems the biggest engineering
challenge for DC was how to get electric
power to the cars the power came through
this slot in the middle of the tracks
that slot could get easily filled with
ice and snow in the winter when you had
cars running in the 20th century and the
cars had chains for snow that the chains
would inevitably get to get jammed into
these slots and country call sorts of
havoc remember that once you had some
kind of jam in in a slot the entire
streetcar line is it's backed up and
told that that's resolved ok so let's
cut to the the age of the automobile
cars and buses arrived and it was a big
turning point is in 1921 the Washington
Rapid Transit company starts running
buses alongside the streetcar line you
can sort of set the scene for me the
buses are zooming by by the streetcars
but well yeah that's yeah that's it's
it's fascinating we don't these days we
don't think of buses as being terribly
sophisticated or exciting but in 1921
they were the buses were seen as this
fabulous new technology and yes the
street cars would be trundling along at
a fixed speed usually about 10 miles an
hour so and they'd be clattering along
and they were these old-fashioned things
that we've seen before and here or these
sleek new
modern buses with the rubber tires just
going freely along the road nimble and
quiet and comfortable and and just so
much better than the old-fashioned
streetcars
what did passengers think of these did
they prefer the old streetcar was the
bus this necessary evil oh no people
preferred the buses when they came out
in fact Connecticut Avenue was unusual
and that it had both buses and
streetcars they were they actually
charged a premium to ride the bus
instead of the streetcar and people paid
it there is a long and and hard to to
kill conspiracy theory out there that
says that that Standard Oil and
Firestone and General Motors conspired
to to eradicate streetcars from American
cities and it is just not true
no in fact people wanted to get rid of
the streetcars
so there's this two point two mile
streetcar that's gonna run along H
Street streetcars and regular cars don't
always coexist so well on the street in
the early days of automobiles were there
issues as well with streetcars and cars
in the traditional way
what's laid out in the center of the
street with islands for passengers to
get on and off the new line runs close
to parked cars it's not the way that the
streetcars were done before and even
before it's open there have been minor
accidents has the age of streetcars
returned is this just the beginning well
yeah that's it's hard to see that
happening the Golden Age of streetcars
if you will from the late 19th early
20th centuries was an age when people
depended on them to be the vital mass
transit system for the city and that
because they didn't have other because
they didn't have other options yes and
and a large very large investment you
know billions of dollars in today's
money was spent on on developing and
maintaining that system and so I don't
think that could same kind of investment
will be made in the modern one and the
modern one there are many other options
now the modern system only has a limited
rationale if you will so I think my
personal feeling is that will it will
remain a limited part of transit in DC
okay John de Ferrari is the author of
the terrific book capital streetcars
early mass transit in Washington DC
thanks for joining us thank you Jim
you